[Music]
it's not making guys and those who are
non-muslims welcome to my channel hope
you guys are doing well
I'm your daily friendly Orthodox Muslim
author of means I follow it to the
traditional way and now I not anybody
now as you guys know Donald Trump has
retweeted he's retweeted Britain first
Britain first is tweet I just want to do
this guy's as you guys know very first
the confrontation and with them and the
madness that she went on I just want to
show you guys something this is really
important because you need to understand
hate and hate pretty should be it's time
extremism and be it far out extremely
more extremism anytime is now developing
and working on the social media platform
it's not like okay come we're gonna sit
in this room in this church on this Moss
and I'm gonna start indoctrinating and
that are uncoordinated no it's working
online to this very second as we speak
now when the President of the United
States gives these guys that boost what
does that tell you about him now what
we're going to do is guys I'm on trader
Franzen a asset is a polish the Polish
immigrant Franzen is the Dutch surname
from a mistaken she's an immigrant
herself trying to pick out other
immigrants and share the problem of
other immigrants isn't that ironic I'm
just gonna scroll down yeah
if you look at everything on the every
single tweet look just check this out
guys it's alright okay look at the
cotesworth Muslims attack English man in
London it stomach mobs pushed teenager
off roof and beaten to death
Muslims wreak havoc in Belgium hello not
welcome in our country was in destroyed
Catholic churches in Italy Muslim
migrants are Dutch boy in crutches
Muslim goes crazy on woman train because
of her shoes crowd gather for public
execution of woman accused of adultery
she forgot to write Muslim death maybe
she was typing in a hurry where else do
we have armed Italian police chase
migrants smuggler Muslim refugees
attempts to rate a woman in China
migrant walks make it etc Muslim this
Muslim this Muslim that Muslim this
Muslim that now guys imagine this right
imagine I make
and all I do is find all these attacks
and hate hate hate should be done by
Christians or by communists or by
whoever it may be familiar black people
for example and all I'm doing on my
pages because a black bear doing this I
look at this for example this Christian
doing this Christian terrorist this
Christian terrorist is Christian this
Christian that's Christian rate this
this is what and how it started in
Germany for the Jews so the Jews being
persecuted and killed six million wiped
off the face of this earth
yeah how did that happen it did not
happen overnight it happened gradually
by demonizing them I see and look at
these bodies Jews okay come and take our
jobs goodies Jews look at always you
know they have this they have that look
at these Jews that doing this this some
mentally reduce this you know what yeah
so you're socially you're
psychologically preparing people and
demonizing Muslims and you're actually
making them out to be not human beings
so then when it comes down to the
nitty-gritty of commented that you can
do that action and kill Muslims because
now you have been prepared to act like
that and think like that and now this is
a crazy movement on its own
everybody knows that yeah now Donald
Trump the PES of the United States of
America to retweet three videos number
one of a supposed Muslim guy beating
this guy on crutches dodge crying being
him secondly some Muslim guys apparent
for in some non Muslim apparently of a
building and thirdly a Muslim man who
seen that he's got this statue of seen
that Virgin Mary and he's breaking it
these free videos was shared retweeted
by Trump what does that tell you about
that person now if there is an
established organization for example at
Isis and they're posting all these
madness stuff the non-muslims are like
this these guys are the same just this
is brain first justice professor
demonizing Muslims Isis its demonizing
non-muslims and also they kill more
Muslims they know knows it anyway and
they say look there's no Muslim Quarter
this they did this they did that Tarara
etc etc and
imagine the leader the president of
another Islamic country retreating that
what what message are you sending across
you need to understand that person has
the exact same ideology as these guys
these guys breakfasts are non violent
extremist to be honest they might even
be violent when I met you said were
combatants and Jesus came to say spread
the sword so they are even declaring
being combatant being violent yeah which
you saw in the video if you're watching
video at the end what is that telling
you guys and these three videos would be
bumped by the touch there was a
newspaper clearly seen the first video
is of a Dutch guy who is Dutch and he's
been born there in the Netherlands yeah
a Dutch guy attacking another person so
the videos aren't even verify they're
fake not fake that it's not happening
that what obvious you can see what's
happening yeah but it's not of a Muslim
the second video is off in 2013 in Egypt
and there were some conflicts going on a
group of individuals from another person
off the building whatever is that got to
do with Islam what on earth has that got
to do with anything
none the third video is firstly we don't
know why that guy was putting a statue
and destroying it let's suppose firstly
we are told in the Quran that we are not
allowed to harm or break other faiths
which means Jannetty judaism hinduism
whatever it may be we are not allowed to
go and attack their religious symbols it
is absolutely forbidden now how could
the president in that states share free
tweets of a hate group hate preachers
violent or nonviolent extremists yet
without verifying and now the
embarrassment you're facing or finding
out that those videos were actually not
verifying so guys that's why I wanted to
do a quick reaction video just to show
you guys that we had we can never learn
anything from our history from our past
because as you can see there same thing
that the Jews went through the Muslims
are going through it step-by-step at the
hands
of these hate preachers on a global
platform I just want you guys to think
about that the President of the United
States of America
tweet tweeted these guys what does that
tell you that should scare every single
one of us of the route that were taking
what was so different what happened in
Nuremberg in in Nazi Germany how the
Jews were vilified step-by-step by
newspapers articles and today that's
happening with social media Muslims are
being vilified and slowly do not be
shocked do not be shocked that a day
might come that a war breaks out you
know and that you start having for
example like Tommy Robinson and Britain
first these individuals were at a hate
rally where with a certain they were
they were celebrating Polish
Independence Day
however they were with a certain group a
Nazi group a white nationalist group
asking for a Muslim Holocaust so let
that sink in guys and let's not have
what was repeated in Germany that was
done to the Jews today happening to the
Muslims hope you guys have benefited
sheds with your friends and family share
subscribe like till next time goodbye
assalamu alaikum